je me suis pris une balle dans le bras
qui est ensuite allé se loger dans la
moelle épinière
[Musique]
réveillant mon blackout petite dizaine
de minutes après je pensais que mes
jambes étaient en l'air et en fait pas
du tout je les jambes à plat et en me
réveillant je me suis dit qu'un jet plus
sensation donc je me suis rendu compte
que je remarche serait plus partir de ce
moment là
[Musique]
il ya forcément eu des coups de mou et
au tout début à l'hôpital ce qu'on se
dit quand même mon avis elle change
quand même un peu radicalement et
mais justement en étant tous les deux
avec meriem qu'on se dit bon ben on va
prendre tous les deux aller de l'avant
ou à repartir on va voir ce qu'on peut
faire ce qu'il veut ça peut devenir
pierre il était en train de se réveiller
dans sa chambre d'hôpital
ils avaient compris qu'ils marcheraient
plus est en fait il était déjà en train
de nous faire des vannes sur le fait
d'être en fauteuil etc
[Musique]
tu préparais le saumon aussi en sortant
de l'hôpital je suis arrivé au centre de
rééducation des invalides j'y ai passé
huit mois qui a été ponctué avec des
séances de kinésithérapie de séance avec
des ergothérapeutes
donc ils sont des personnes qui t'aident
à réapprendre les gestes de la vie
quotidienne que ce soit faire la cuisine
faire le ménage et même quand en
fauteuil roulant ont effectué
réapprennent tes appuis et ses huit mois
nous aurait six permis d'attendre
d'avoir un appartement accessible ce qui
est assez rare dans paris 1 et tout ça
on l'apprend ensemble leur éducation et
c'est eux qui t'apprennent à pouvoir
remonter dans sa voiture et de pouvoir
pouvoir être autonome comme n'importe
qui
et donc là on a la chance d'avoir un
appartement parce que c'est pas trop le
cas dans paris d'avoir un appartement où
on peut se balader facilement sans avoir
de problèmes de côté étriqué ou autres
qui nous permet d'accéder à toutes les
pièces de l'appartement que ce soit la
salle de bains où notre chambre ou ou la
première pièce c'est pour ça qu'on a une
cuisine qui est plutôt aux normes
enfin qui est plutôt standard avec un
plan à 90 cm de haut est le seul endroit
où c'est accessible c'est ce qui était
déjà prévu dans l'appartement quand on
est arrivé et c'est l'évier qui lui je
peux passer tout sans problème pour
aller faire la vaisselle ancienne maison
je me remets à chercher un boulot à
retrouver du boulot
iyaz irma me tiens ça leur donne un
rythme parce que c'est souvent ça lui si
le problème pour les personnes
handicapées c'est qu'il ya plus c'est
soit un peu laissé aller soit on se bat
du laisser aller mais c'est se dire bon
ménage et plus de j'ai plus de boulot je
vais plus rien faire de mes journées g
potentiellement il y en a qui sortent
plus de chez 2 donc ça c'était pas conçu
pour moi
on n'a pas arrêté de sortir on n'a pas
arrêté de faire des activités signer
culture théâtre c'est là que tu te rends
compte qu'en fait il ya beaucoup de
choses qui sont accessibles
j'ai eu la chance de faire pas mal de
rencontres qui m'ont permis de
changer de fauteuil d'avoir un fauteuil
et qui est plus actif qui te permet de
faire plus de plus d'activité de plus
facilement de déplacer dans la ville
et ensuite c'est des rencontres qui
m'ont permis de me remettre au sport je
me suis mis au tennis
là ça m'a donné envie d'aller au
aller faire du ski on est partis au ski
avec myriam on est allé faire une
semaine complète de réapprentissage de
ski assis
[Musique]
avec une association qu'on a créé en
novembre 2018 qui s'appelle wild world
on s'est dit on va faire en sorte de
montrer à la fois aux valides pour
ouvrir ce point de vue là pour eux est à
la fois pour les personnes handicapées
pour qu'elle puisse elle même aussi s'en
rendre compte que c'est pas parce qu'on
est en situation de handicap qu'on peut
pas partir à l'étranger et notamment
dans des pays qui sont moins accessibles
que d'autres donc valais graziella machu
picchu au pérou on va aller faire du
tandem électrique en nouvelle zélande on
va gravir le kilimandjaro en tanzanie et
on va aller faire les on va aller
participer aux jo paralympiques à tokyo
aujourd'hui je me rends bien compte que
on me dit qu'une fois donc on en profite
à fond j'ai envie d'avoir une vie comme
les autres et donc
je me donne les moyens pour et fait ma
vie je suis en fauteuil roulant mais il
ma vie elle est comme avant